you mentioned one time that
valet told you about how these alphabet
agencies work and that you were able to
see how they work up close and personal
i think in terms of the strategies that
they use though i wasn't sure exactly
what you meant by the strategies like
you mean the disinformation strategies
like what are you refer the collection
of
of data strategies the silencing of
people i wasn't sure what you meant so
do you mind expounding on that yeah some
of the strategies that they use would be
there were two specific ways in which
they spread disinformation at least when
project blue book was going on and i
believe they probably still do this and
i think probably yeah this is this is
what i've experienced up close um
they cultivate two types of people as
assets and when i say assets those
people sometimes don't even know that
they're being cultivated in fact they
don't know um and that's why they're
assets is because they're an asset to be
there are you being used right uh to
propagate misinformation one of those
persons is like the benefits you know
have you heard of uh paul benovitz
who i've heard
yeah so this was a a person who was not
mentally
stable
and but was near an air force base and
believed in ufos and
rick dodi richard dodi who worked for
the air force as a special agent
he
um he targeted
benefits
and put stuff on his computer to make
him think that
a ufo invasion was imminent okay
and then of course benefits then looks
crazy right or crazier so you know
vulnerable people like that they're
targeted and they're used to kind of
create a stigma associated with ufos if
crazy people believe in ufos i don't
want to believe in them you see what i'm
saying so that happened and then also um
linda molten howe they went for people
like her who
was a legitimate journalist right she
has some credentials from stanford and
they target her and they give her
misinformation and they bring her on
base or something like that and they say
look this is going to come out so those
are two ways that you get cultivated as
an asset
um you're not an asset to yourself or
your life or your family but you're
their asset now where they're you know
cultivating you so um there was a point
in my research where i basically severed
all ties with anybody in the invisible
college except for
jacques who i do trust and gary okay and
gary by the way is not technically in
the invisible college um
he's an invisible one
he's a visible one right but um but yeah
so i just didn't want that in my life at
all because you know i wanted to do
straight up research i didn't want to
to you know because my research could
easily be used to
further some agenda because i'm doing
historical research that's showing that
these things are that these very strange
aerial phenomena have been around
if i didn't do that research i didn't
know this
i would assume that there's some kind of
a program like a weapons program going
on that's what i would think was was
happening at this point now there might
be a weapons program going on in which
case my research would be valuable to
them
so how do i do my research and and you
know stop from being cultivated so i
guess at some point i recognize that
that that's a real thing
and um
i mean it kind of recognized it already
because i wasn't sure what was going on
in american cosmic at the beginning but
i'm a researcher who's honest and i said
that in almost every chapter with tyler
i basically said you know james and i
and james is gary i'd say we weren't
quite sure if we were being set up for
misinformation or not but subsequently
james actually went you know gary went
along and you know checked out the
debris and found that it was very
strange and so
you know something's happening